you know what it is it's nothing to do
with religion
World Order
yes
you got children yes I do they go to
school
so what does this represent
I don't know
foreign
that we don't like what's his name
Satan that's right yeah what does Satan
what's his purpose Satan to confuse
people that's right
confuse people and misguide them and
this guy
so what what do you think Satan is
trying to do right now who's trying to
do right now to come to 10 people away
from God through Christianity and
Judaism and enthusian and Buddhism all
right let me tell you what he's doing
I'll tell you what he's really trying to
do the Bible says that Satan is a father
of Lies you agree with that that he's a
murderer
all right let me show you something else
but you haven't dealt with my friends
you're talking about transformation
right
if you accept God to be good and to be
perfect
you believe God Jesus further than the
man same time but you said perfect
imperfect yeah it's Jesus not perfect
and man so why do you follow him
he said no one
so if God knows everything why are you
here
because I'm a big sinner I have lied I
have stolen right I have fornicated
right I am wicked so that's why I need
Jesus okay so now can I speak now all
right so what are yours what are you can
you offer me and you offer me salvation
yes
all right go on okay islamically that's
the beauty of Islam as a Muslims I don't
want to expose myself to anyone rather
instead teach us Prophet Muhammad said
one of the major sins one of the main
sin to go expose your sins you
understand because the Bible says
differently he says who confessions
that's why the Western world full of
sins because why they're following the
Bible
no anyway let me finish now islamically
Allah told us in the Quran he's a
beautiful verse and he has no verse like
this in any Scripture in Arabic
said to everyone
those who transgress no innocence those
who want beyond the boundaries they
commit too much sins don't despair from
Allah's Mercy Allah forgive all the sins
my beautiful verse what a beautiful
voice
read this verse they give them
right if you don't realize this God has
a court
in this country we have a court in Saudi
we they have a court and the reason we
don't just forgive people is because
there is one thing that's needed before
you can get forgiveness confession you
must confess that you have broken God's
law and if you don't have the law The
Ten Commandments how can you be like the
person who says I'm good because I have
done I'm all right Allah forgive me
Allah
no Jesus says I am the way the truth and
the life no man cometh to the father
about my need that is why this flag is
so important
you know what Jesus said Jesus said to
the Cross he says father you know what
he said he said Lord if it be possible
father take this cup away from me what
was the cup it was this the cross that
he had to Bear our sins okay
no he said to you why he cannot forgive
and he said he cannot you you better
blasphemy against God because in the
Bible in the Old Testament if you go to
Ezekiel he says that if someone commits
a wickedness and it was a wicked and he
said the weapon with wickedness and it
doesn't righteous Deeds God will forgive
him
no no no no why repenting to God
no no no no no get the Bible
yes
and and doesn't make any sense in order
to forgive someone you have to punish
him because somebody has to be punished
if your wife come into adultery if your
wife does it you're not gonna be a happy
man
he has to be punished then there has to
be somebody who can take away that Sin
from you the Bible says the Lamb of God
alhamdulillah
God will never forgive you have to
punish you all right
Ezekiel I was reading it today so how
can we don't know it I know it I know
which number is it it's well it could be
33. no it's not 29. there's much
18 18.
[Music]
foreign foreign
[Laughter]
places they had committed and keep all
my status and you do that which is a
lawful and right he surely live and why
is very interesting here it's very
similar to Allah in the Quran the Allah
and the meaning of the verse if you
commit sins and you turn away from it
and you do righteous Deeds then Allah
will forgive you and you'll be from the
people Paradise so he never said you
have to die for No One sins if you
commit to Wicked and you tell me from
way away from the wickedness and the sin
then you shall not die meaning that you
should have the eternal life not be a
new time because everyone would die all
right except Allah
all
his transgressions that he had committed
that shall not be mentioned unto him
so that it teaches you exactly what
Allah mentioned if you commit sin
there's no need to remind the people of
your sins because God told you here if
you if you turn away from it there's no
need to mention them okay that shall not
be mentioned unto him in his
righteousness that you have done he
shall live how about any pleasure that
order so this is the week it shall die
okay so this is my point here I just
showed you clear passage in the Old
Testament and there's many many you can
go to Genesis therefore not Genesis
sorry deutronomy many passages in the
Old Testament never teach us no one
should be responsible for no one seems
well let me show you where the Bible
says let me show you from this work of
Genesis
if you commit sin you should not be
responsible for anyone should be
responsible for it all right
you know the Old Testament yeah Jeremiah
Daniel all the prophets and messages
never taught people that someone should
be commit suicide for God to forgive the
sins
and then Jesus comes imagine just I'll
finish with this yeah and I'll give you
a time as well yeah yeah okay imagine
from Moses I mean before the Abraham
Noah Jacob azak Jeremiah Daniel
Isaiah all the prophets and Messengers
came with a specific teaching there's
one God also that if you commit sins and
away from it and to rush of this then
who comes after opening to the Christian
according to us Jesus he said I'm gonna
die for your sins then who comes after
him Prophet Muhammad
what does he say he said that if you
commit sin you don't want to be
responsible for it so the one that is
following the old prophets and messages
Prophet Muhammad the one that is going
to guess the old prophets and messages
the opportunity you believe is Jesus
therefore Jesus of the Christians is a
false prophet all right okay all right
let's see let's see what the Bible
actually says about that God sets a man
in the in the book that he commanded the
man not to eat of every tree of the
garden
yes
now is Adam the first man that was ever
ever lived you agree we all agree yeah
so we all agree that Adam was a first
man God gave adam the Commandments he
did not give his wife the Commandments
his wife went and took the tree took off
the tree the fruit you agree with that
no no we don't believe that wasn't
committed sin all right
no I didn't say I'm not blaming anything
the woman took my throat no no he didn't
say that I'll show you the woman I can
show you okay all right the Bible says a
woman took the fruits okay and she ate
and gave to her husband who was with her
but I was giving you the secrets yeah
suggested right yeah
he's not a liar well if this is the case
then and you both agree that we serve
the same God Allah
in a way yes but in other way no because
you self Jesus is good all right well
let me say what God said he says
he says about of the three of the
knowledge of the good and evil thou
shall not eat of it for in the day that
thou eat us thereof thou shall surely
die God said this the Lord said this to
Adam
he said in that day you are going to die
now if he died in that day we are not
here today are we because Adam was the
one who was our greatest grandfather
when I mentioned my passages it was so
clear he's unclear what I mean it's not
clear what were you talking about
earlier
oh well you can't chop and change it
according to what you like you've got to
take everything and guess you because
you believe in it you understand
something right so what happened let me
remind you yeah yeah we were talking
about taking responsible for the sins
yes I'm talking about this
I'm not
sure no no no no he showed me out of
context
let's get the context let's get the
context where's the context the context
is always taken from the book of Genesis
that's not the context how the context
go back to different you have to go back
to the first book of the Bible no
problem go back to the first book show
me where you go I am going to give it to
you I'm going to give it to you right so
God said to Adam that if he eats up that
tree he will die in that day did he die
that day no he doesn't why why not I
don't believe what he said I don't
believe that oh crying out loud then why
are we talking
you want all right so you want them all
right so let's see what let's see folks
Muslims let's see what really happens
no let me see let me show you what
really happened God
was said to them that you're gonna die
Adam if you eat them they're gonna die
what do you mean die physically no it
doesn't mean that oh Crying Out Loud
come on
when you mention about if you commit or
die and if you do not commit if you do
righteousness you will live no doubt
even couldn't you believe Jesus who was
a righteousness he did die open do you
believe so die and Alive here means that
if you commit sin then you turn away
from God's Kingdom right if you turn
away from your sin then you will live
mean you will gain God's kingdom that is
not what the Lord said the Lord said in
the day that thou eat us thereof about
the day
we have one 24-hour day unless you
believe a day so where in the Bible says
if you commit sin you will die you know
about Adam all right let's let's go
let's let me start with Genesis first
okay we always go so far as a Christian
as a person who believes in Jesus we
always start with Genesis okay now let
me show you what God did it's called all
right because you're impatient and you
know what Muslims have to be patient
yeah we as Christians we're about to be
putting up with a lot of sin for a lot
of time we are patients all right
all right so let's see what let's see
what God did when he when God found out
that Adam and Eve had sinned why do you
know the Bible says see if you consult
here brother said he called his wife's
name Eve because he was a mother of all
living read verse 21. Adam also and to
his wife did the Lord God make the coat
of skins of skins
yeah anybody got anybody got a leather
coat on here Jamaica Jamaica what's the
point all right the point is yeah in
order for you to have a skin what do you
have to happen you have to have a
chicken a chicken all right so no listen
man listen in order for you to have skin
and clothe you with skin yeah like a
leather garment you have the actual skin
you have to slay and Slaughter the
animal okay all right now what happens
when you slow Muslims are notice in
Ramadan I think in your countries there
is a lot of slaughtering
sorry sorry brother sorry
so there's a lot of food a lot of lambs
a lot of lambs being right yes yes
where's the vegan right no we don't have
vegans in Islam of course not because we
all eat lamb yeah
by the way
fun thing for you you know what Islam
really means
I'm gonna put an L at the beginning
all right no I'm only kidding here is
what I believe in Jamaica yes I am
I'm Jamaica yeah okay so here is what
I'm really saying without the following
that the Bible that was hold on hold on
everybody respects this book
I mean yes
what you're gonna all remember my name
I'm gonna spell it for you a l l a n
they couldn't cut the tail off and you
get
Act of righteousness yes what does it
mean the ship is taking your sins no it
doesn't listen I believe
any Jews in the house where are the Jews
[Music]
I'll tell you it doesn't make any sense
because
[Music]
what is
this is wonderful
[Applause]
[Music]
listen guys Jesus loves the Saudis too
that's a good question so we love Jesus
nice very good mango
manga manga it's righteousness
it's a simple religion
stay away from the fourth boats and
messenger that came to teach us about
the book I believe I was alive Jesus
before Jesus was Moses that's why one of
the six pillars for Faith one of the
more one of the most important is to
Believe In The Messengers of God there
is no muslim so any Muslim reject Jesus
or Moses he cannot be a Muslim anymore
in Jesus of course rather in the Quran
you know you know there's a chapter in
the Quran is the name of the mother of
Jesus but there's no chapter in the
Quran named after the mother of Muhammad
if the Quran was made by Prophet
Muhammad why he's going to name a
chapter after a mother of someone else
but not after his own mother because
that Quran it was the almighty so what
Allah
there was a lot of Jewish people and
they were spreading that Jesus
he defended Jesus but you know what if
he was if when he was defending Jesus he
lost followers
is all people they used to look up to
the Jewish people so if they agreed with
the Jewish people that yes Jesus was a
messiah then they would accept him and
he will get more followers but to show
you that Prophet Muhammad he didn't care
about followers he cared about what God
tell him to say so why was doing
defending the owner and the Dignity of
Jesus against the Jewish people even
though he knows by doing that the people
gonna go against him and he's going to
gain any benefit by doing that from
would leave point of view but no doubt
he's a true Messenger so my friend if
you study about the biography of our
Prophet Muhammad clearly this man is a
messenger of God and the prophet Jesus
mentioned many times
Jesus was from the one who's closest to
God you understand so we believe the one
that we don't like is cold and
Constantine have you don't notice
oh Paul my favorites
both of them had dreams and above them
changed what the teaching of God because
if you notice Paul he said is not about
action anymore it's about faith all
right then we have Constantine in the
first century he had a dream oh he's so
efficient that he saw the cross behind
the son and what happened and so to just
to justify the war and get the people
and guess what what was Constantine's
father and Constantine when he was young
what they used to believe in the sun oh
yeah yeah we know that and they become
real Christian when they did the son
called Jesus
one more question for you guys and then
I can wrap this one I have one another
question okay is Muhammad still alive
because Muhammad yes in Paradise no is
he alive here is he no he's not here it
is here how did he die no before you
tell me how he died
when Muhammad died
where did he go Paradise Paradise okay
did he show himself to his followers
after he died
in dreams in dreams
no because it's in the Bible
in the Bible okay well how are we gonna
have a chance
it's a resurrection and the life is he
alive Jesus Oh yes
I'm asking a question
from the dead prove that to me
why Islam is the truth we don't believe
Islam is the truth because we have the
vision who had a dream no that's the
beach in Islam bro yeah that's why Islam
is spreading efficient is dying no no
it's not but oh no it's not everybody
wants to come to me everybody wants to
come to England
all right
they know where the blessing is
no man